you've made it to the last lab in the
quest after you complete this lab on
quick laps you will finally unlock your
badge are you familiar with quick lab
quests quests are a series of labs
organized by technologies specific
services or particular use cases there's
no need to complete an entire quest in a
single sitting but by completing each
individual lab in a quest you can earn
badges that reflect your newly acquired
skills on this episode we're gonna go
over what you'll learn in this final lab
in the GCP essentials quest and set up
networking HTTP load balancers in this
hands-on lab you'll learn the
differences between a networked load
balancer and an HTTP load balancer and
how to set them up for your applications
running on Google compute engine virtual
machines this lab will take you through
the steps to set up two types of load
balancers in Google cloud platform l3
network load balancer l7 HTTP load
balancer you will create an instance
template with a specified startup script
create a target pool to allows a single
access point to all instances in a group
create a managed instance group using
the instance template with two VMs view
the created instances and configure a
firewall to connect to the machines on
port 80 create a level three network
load balancer targeting the instance
group we created list a forwarding rules
in our project to see the target of our
group is our instance group and use the
IP address of the low balancer to visit
the low balancer from a browser and the
remainder of the lab you will also
create an HTTP load balancer is this it
is this the last lab on your quest
congratulations we want to hear from you
tell us about your experience following
this quick labs quest and how you're
applying what you've learned in your own
applications in the comments below see
you next month will will embark on our
next quest baseline infrastructure